as it seems to happen every few months  certain politicians are making a big  stink about section 230 of the  communications decency act the funny  thing is that if they were successful in  repealing section 230 it would be  disastrous for those politicians  because it does two things number one it  allows platforms to moderate  and number two it provides a shield so  that if a user posts something  the platform isn't responsible for that  post and while a lot of people are mad  about the moderation  if that shield was destroyed a lot of  those accounts the ones that are at risk  that are peddling conspiracy theories  and are possibly defamatory would be  simply  shut down the first one to be shut down  probably president trump's  so as the old proverb says be careful  what you wish for i did a whole video on  this in the past check it out  and if you like this video check out my  other eagle briefs where i cover the  legal issues of the day and as always  i'll see you  in court